[Music]
peruvians confront Security forces in
puno south of the country one month
after 18 people were killed there in the
worst day of unrest since president
dinabaluarte took office in December
tensions are rising
legislators hold the key to the crisis
voting to bring elections forward but
they've shelled nearly every proposal
congresswoman susel Paredes presented
one of the bills she says legislators
bear some of the responsibility nearly
60 people have been killed
I wonder if my fellow congressmen can
sleep comfortably at night because one
that Peruvian is a family and a country
in mourning legislators have the
responsibility to give the country a
political solution
on Friday Congress extended sessions yet
for another week without making any
decision president boluarte could bring
elections forward by resigning she says
she won't instead she blames the violent
protests for the instability
we've left behind the dark history of
the 80s and 90s the country doesn't have
to bleed anymore
the government passed a supreme decree
to give the Army control of several
districts in the south of the country
not a political solution in the most
conflicted areas
opinion polls say more than 80 percent
of peruvians are demanding early
elections but analysts say Congress and
the government are turning their backs
on the people's demands
analysts say there is a silent pact
between the government and Parliament to
stay in power
that's basically a silent Alliance if
there's something that unites the
Parliament and the government it's the
idea of remaining in power until 2026
it's not official but it's very much
endorsed
without a political solution analy say
there is little chance of ending pedu's
ongoing political crisis
Lima